when it becomes okay
to you know damage people's properties
and
wake them up in the middle of the night
when terror is seen as
justified i think it's inevitable that
something terrible
is going to happen on saturday august
29th a pro-trump demonstrator was shot
and killed during ongoing street
protests in portland
last week i interviewed veteran
journalist nancy rommelman who has
covered the portland protest for reason
and has talked to dozens of
demonstrators trying to understand their
mindsets
and motivations she worries that as the
protest movement continues
it's becoming increasingly rest of
unfocused
and headed into dangerous territory we
go into 2020 which is obviously going to
be an election year
then covet hits businesses closed and
the city
closed and downtown became kind of
barren the schools are closed
and everybody's home including tons and
tons of young people
and then george floyd is killed and the
city explodes
for a very long time they wore peaceful
protests you know moms and kids in the
the line of cars that go around tutu but
per usual these things you've got a
small contingent that wants to
[ __ ] [ __ ] up they showed up down at
justice center they broke the windows
they threw furniture around they set a
fire i wrote a piece for a reason about
a woman that was trapped in the basement
the problem is
the mayor and the city council basically
just said
you're not going to arrest peaceful
protesters they stand they keep
committing violence
against the justice center and also next
door which is the federal building
in late july a special response team
from u.s customs and border patrol
showed up in tactical gear ostensibly to
protect
federal property there were many bloody
confrontations
in which protesters were tear gassed and
some were caught on camera
being pulled into unmarked vans nobody
wants to be tear gassed but
you've been pelting the building with
flaming trash for three hours
provoking a reaction they are still
calling this free speech
but they're terrorizing citizens and
they march to the nearest place
that they feel must be overtaken
police stations police unions a social
services building
uh ice headquarters they trash it they
set fire to it and they go into the
residential streets
now they're shining lights into people's
windows and saying
get up [ __ ] get up i'm out here
every night fighting for change
and we want you to know that and we want
you to be uncomfortable
some of these people are 20 years old
and i have said to them you know
what is it that you want and it's like
deep on the place it's like okay
all right so then where do we go from
there i was at
a march where the police remained
entirely passive
entirely late they finally came out
because their union was being burnt down
for the that burnt down there was a fire
there they were pelting it
for the umptee at the time they finally
just stood there
all the protesters like she got this
close in their faces and then they just
turned around and left
that was by order of ted wheeler
i understand this idea they're trying to
provoke us if we
don't be provoked maybe it dies down but
there's too much momentum
and if it stays this hot i think it's
inevitable that something
terrible is going to happen and then
whatever
side that terrible thing happens to uses
to say look now we're justified in doing
x
if you're a 22 year old and you're home
and you're not in school anymore maybe
your job has gone away because a lot of
jobs were
lost in portland you really are lost
and you are maybe lost for identity and
maybe you're looking for identity and
you're looking for people to hang out
with
and then you find it and then you put on
a you know an
outfit and you go out every night and
you feel energized and i've had people
tell me this it's like
it really is an incredible feeling of
being
part of something rommelman worries that
a moral blindness
is overtaking the protesters i think
that when
the definition of free speech or
peaceful protest starts to become very
elastic when terror
is seen as justified we've seen how
these things go
and they blame white supremacists of
portland or the city government or the
cops
and they see what they're doing as
creating some sort of justice